I mean there's just this point to where
I think a lot of people don't understand
you just got a do [ __ ] that you hate
sometimes to get to where you need to be
yeah and a lot of people don't get that
they go I just want to do things that I
like always it's like well good [ __ ]
luck yes if that was the case and I
always tell young people about this too
is that you need to stop trying to
satisfy everything with your career yeah
meaning that you want your career to be
the happiest thing the most soul
satisfying thing make you a [ __ ] ton of
money you'll fix your family problems
everything can and it doesn't work like
that too and so like people always ask
they go like here's the thing that a lot
of people didn't know when I started
doing YouTube I wanted to quit after the
first year yeah cuz I hated it yeah
[ __ ] hated YouTube like I [ __ ]
hated it the only reason why I stayed
was because of Barton Joe yeah Bartow
Barton Joe told me to stick with it and
because it was gonna go somewhere it
would open or the doors which it did but
I was a stand-up comic I mean like doing
stand-up yeah and then my youtube videos
at the time were failed stand-up comedy
bits that I RiRi worked into three
minute segments I was really [ __ ] loud
because I heard that people had a short
attention span on YouTube and I wouldn't
be able to tell a story like I do was
stand up so I developed this [ __ ]
loud loud character and I just did it
you know and so for me when I was doing
those videos I'll be it too like I
really enjoyed the fact that people were
laughing at it cuz at the end of the day
was standing up I just want people to
laugh and if you laugh from it made me
feel good but for me I had to relive my
broken stand-up sets and put it into
these videos yeah yeah right so I didn't
want to do that [ __ ] and then it led to
other things and other opportunities
because they just see that you oh you
went from here to here it's like no it's
like YouTube was hard for me like that
first year I wanted to quit you know
yeah yeah I mean I tried it and I was
like hell no I can't do this I was like
well I totally underestimated this I was
like no I could just you know kind of
post and when I want and I'll do
something once a week but like hell no
man that [ __ ] is he's a full-time job
and and trying it for a few months I was
like this isn't business for me like it
really is a full-time job and I always
tell people they go oh well I could do
YouTube and this I was like YouTube is
something that you become successful
doing part-time yeah it doesn't work
that way it takes everything out of you
yeah and a lot of younger kids now their
dream
to become a youtuber which [ __ ] blows
my mind yeah and that's like a career
choice now yeah this for you to want to
be a youtuber and that whole space was
such a such a weird part for a lot of
people but on the other hand too
I think a lot of youtubers don't get the
other side of acting and film because
they're so used to doing everything
within their control and then they don't
understand that when you [ __ ] with other
people's money you have no [ __ ] say
yeah
it's very true which was the hardest
reason why I couldn't get auditions and
I couldn't get an agent yeah because
they had such a bad taste from working
with youtubers yeah they would expect
the world because they're so used to
having everybody say yes and do whatever
they want and so they would go to these
auditions and I'm not gonna drop any
names but [ __ ] you guys but you guys
would go to these auditions and then you
would act as if the role was already
yours just because of who you were on
this online presence yeah it's like well
that's great
[ __ ] four-year-olds watching they're
not gonna watch this film you [ __ ]
dumbass ya know and they they didn't get
their roles like oh they just don't know
what they missed done they know what
they missed out on you suck as a [ __ ]
actor you trash bag yeah and then I
would try to get like auditions and
they're like no he's a youtuber don't
[ __ ] with him yeah and we did [ __ ] and
then it flipped yeah [ __ ] finally you
know yeah yeah is that crazy they're
like I do feel like it's it there's such
a adjustment period like for youtubers
and the whole YouTube world coming into
mainstream sort of consciousness and I
feel now it's kind of balanced out like
yeah
like you can cross over if you're if you
got the right you know if you have your
head on straight and but also like you
know youtubers are also like considered
just as much celebrities and as anybody
else oh for sure and they have to
understand too it's like if you're a
youtuber and you go like well I could do
this to the other other well that's just
a different realm and you have to
respect that art for what it is right
yeah so just as the same as they
probably can't do what you do you can't
do what they exactly yeah and I think
that's that's what's funny is like in
this in entertainment everybody tries to
create this hierarchy unscripted
scripted television film indie film like
it's it's all sort of people try to find
a way to like say oh I'm better than you
yeah you know weird been which is like
everyone's just creating [ __ ] like like
what's the reason to operate that way
well you know they they like they like
people to be put in their place for some
[ __ ] reason
yeah like never understand that [ __ ] you
know they go well like for example like
I always say if you're if you're on a
YouTube space or if you came from vine
or Instagram don't think that you being
able to take 30 [ __ ] takes of you
reworking a joke and be able to do that
when you're on an improv show oh hell no
good [ __ ] luck you have good on that
spot yeah I learn how to do here yes
ends and if you don't know how to do
that your [ __ ] fire and they found
out there's like a couple of people who
came up on wild and out not Tim like
killed in a while the now yeah but
there's a couple of youtubers Asian
youtubers that tried coming onto that
stage and I've heard from quite a few
people on that cast they were like they
were trash because they're so used to
talking to Kim yo what's up blah blah
blah blah and you know talking big but
when you're put on stage in front of
people you have to improv and you have
to act and do your [ __ ] yeah trash yeah
and that's just to say like you
underestimated what other people did
yeah no you looked at that what they did
was easy
yeah and it's not yeah they got rekt the
guy that's [ __ ] great but you did um
you did a second film that got into
Sundance miss purple yeah what how did
you start miss purple so you know I was
hoping to shoot a another film that I'm
actually gonna shoot next month but I
was ready to shoot that last year and
that film is with macro this company
that made you know sorry to bother you
mud bound and slew of other amazing
films but um I just don't think we were
ready so I was like okay I was also on
an ABC show and it was in between
seasons I didn't know if it would get
picked up for a second Caesar or not if
it did get picked up I wouldn't be able
to direct anything for another like year
yeah yeah so I was like [ __ ] man I don't
want to stay out of the director's chair
that long because then I'm gonna get
rusty and yeah so uh miss purple was an
idea that I had for years you know I
really wanted
make a story about siblings specifically
like a brother and sister I just don't
see that in film a lot and I also wanted
to tell a story about you know a family
that that are from k-town you know that
is from k-town and Koreatown now is so
gentrified